[Música]
hola soy natalia cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida aquí américa este es el
magazine de france 24 para revisar en
profundidad las noticias e historias de
nuestro continente y este es nuestro
recorrido de hoy
empezamos en eeuu porque yo bailé en
llamó dictador y asesinó a su homólogo
ruso vladimir putin las desgarradoras
imágenes que deja la invasión del
ejército del kremlin a ucrania han
despertado en la unión americana un
sentimiento anti ruso que no se vivía
desde la guerra fría les contamos más
desde washington y seguimos en el sur
del continente en colombia que se
prepara para las elecciones
presidenciales en medio de un repunte de
la violencia por el control de las rutas
del narcotráfico entre disidentes de la
extinta guerrilla de las farc y la del
autodenominado ejército de liberación
nacional que dejan a los civiles en la
mitad
y vamos a perú porque el tribunal
constitucional autorizó la liberación
del expresidente alberto fujimori
sentenciado a 25 años de prisión por
violaciones a los derechos humanos de
los cuales solo ha purgado 15 hablamos
con las víctimas
y vamos de inmediato con nuestra
historia principal ni la retórica ni las
sanciones han detenido los ataques del
ejército de vladimir putin sobre ucrania
que afectan especialmente a los civiles
la organización de naciones unidas-
corroboró la muerte de más de 700
personas las terribles imágenes que
llegan desde territorio ucraniano han
desatado una fobia rusa en eeuu que no
se veía desde la guerra fría según la
oficina descenso en la unión americana
viven cerca de un millón de rusos y hay
más de 3 millones de ruso americanos
tras la invasión a ucrania por parte del
presidente putin han crecido las
intimidaciones contra los negocios rusos
y algunos de los que viven en washington
denuncian que aunque están en desacuerdo
con la guerra y viven a cientos de
kilómetros de distancia su vida diaria
también se está viendo afectada nuestro
corresponsal en washington cristóbal
vázquez habló con ellos
y mi tribal web es un ruso que vive hace
más de 10 años en washington con su
esposa nadie protesta desde que empezó
la guerra y ucrania para desmarcarse de
la decisión de [__] ucranianos y
americanos me dan la mano y me dan su
visto bueno y me agradecen por venir y
por manifestar no necesitamos más voces
y estoy contento de que no soy el único
ruso que lo está haciendo hay rusos en
otras ciudades que apoyan a ucrania hay
muchos rusos en rusia que están contra
putin
nadie va nueva esposa de dimitri usa la
distancia con su tierra natal para
pronunciarse contra el kremlin su
familia en rusia también en desacuerdo
con la guerra ha sido intimidad
la gente tiene miedo de hablar porque es
imposible apoyar la guerra y posible
decir si matamos gente no creo que esto
pueda pasar la gente está atemorizada
creo que la verdad se conocerá después
de que putin deje el poder entonces los
rusos podrán decir lo que piensan
la comunidad rusa en eeuu que no apoyan
su totalidad a la guerra vive por obvias
razones tiempos difíciles dice hosting
lugar analista del instituto cato
creo que los estadounidenses deberían
superar esto creo que deberían darse
cuenta que en el caso de los rusos en
eeuu
estas personas son casi más
estadounidenses que los que nacieron acá
ellos aman y sienten el privilegio de
vivir en este país sin am en escape
al día y dmitri hacen parte de la
organización watch foundation que hace
activismo contra putin como millones de
ucranianos ellos no podrán regresar
pronto a su país este es mi miedo en
ucrania que todo el país va a ser
destruido muchas personas van a ser
asesinadas y creemos que podemos hacer
más desde acá que desde una prisión rusa
podemos ser más activos y conectarnos
con más personas que en una celda allá
desde que empezó la invasión en ucrania
el número de negocios rusos a
vandalizados en eeuu ha aumentado
restaurantes como gràcia house en
washington han sido atacados varias
veces a pesar de propiedad de un
estadounidense una fobia contra los
rusos que revive fantasmas de la guerra
fría
vamos ahora a colombia que tras las
elecciones legislativas se prepara para
las presidenciales de mayo el país está
experimentando un resurgimiento de la
violencia entre grupos armados en
algunas regiones es el caso de arauca en
la frontera con venezuela donde la
guerrilla de ln y los disidentes de las
farc están disputándose el control de la
zona que es rica en petróleo y es
estratégica para el tráfico de cocaína
entre el intercambio de balas están los
civiles y los líderes sociales veamos el
informe de un equipo de france 24 que
fue hasta saravena
en el pequeño pueblo oriental colombiano
de saravena las calles están acordonadas
sus residentes viven con miedo a los
coches-bomba el último estuvo dirigido
al edificio donde trabajaban sonia y
juan carlos
en la cima
era el 19 de enero
realmente ibas para hacer el movimiento
políticas más sociales y populares del
centro-oriente colombia el coche bomba
tenía como blanco el cuartel general de
su movimiento político de izquierda son
en juan carlos son los líderes de esta
organización política la noche de la
explosión se habían reunido con cerca de
60 líderes sociales estos barriles
llenos de piedras bloquearon la calle y
les salvaron la vida para nosotros los
tipos de van a meter el narrador ha sido
desastroso para los otros el ataque dejó
un muerto y cinco heridos las
autoridades responsabilizan a disidentes
de la extinta guerrilla de las farc sus
enemigos otro grupo guerrillero el
ejército de liberación nacional que ha
estado presente en la región durante
tres décadas ha dicho que alguno de los
liderazgos sociales pertenecería a algún
frente urbano del ejército de liberación
los dos grupos armados libran una guerra
despiadada la meta el control de esta
ciudad un área estratégica para los
múltiples tipos de tráfico que pasan por
el río arauca en la frontera con
venezuela
josé luís es el único funcionario
dedicado a proteger los derechos básicos
de la población
escoltado por este guardia motorizado
está abrumado por los pedidos de ayuda
esta vez este representante vecinal y su
esposa están sufriendo amenazas
visitado en esto
y
viven muchos vecinos y muchos amigos
desde el comienzo del año el conflicto
ha dejado unos 100 muertos en esta
región fronteriza
que se entienda que no todo el que aquel
porque esté aliado con uno u otro grupo
sino por el simple hecho de haber nacido
acá pues nos lleva a tener un proyecto
de vida acá muy bien
como si respondieran a los graffitis
territoriales de los grupos guerrilleros
han comenzado a aparecer pinturas en las
paredes de saravena símbolos de una
población atrapada en un fuego cruzado
que ruega a estos grupos armados que por
fin hagan la paz vamos a mexico para
revisar la cifra de la semana 8 ese es
el número de periodistas que han sido
asesinados en lo ocurrido de 2022 el más
reciente fue armando linares el director
del medio digital monitor michoacán que
fue agredido a disparos a las afueras de
su casa y nadie venía denunciando
amenazas tras el asesinato en enero de
un colega del mismo medio roberto toledo
luego de haber revelado corrupción de
funcionarios estatales según reporteros
sin fronteras méxico es uno de los
países más peligrosos del mundo para
ejercer la profesión
y sigamos en nuestro recorrido por
américa en perú el tribunal
constitucional dio luz verde a la
liberación del ex presidente alberto
fujimori fujimori fue condenado en 2009
a 25 años de prisión por violaciones a
los derechos humanos pero en 2017 el
entonces presidente pedro pablo
kuczynski lo indultó y ordenó su
liberación por su estado de salud luego
el mismo tribunal supremo que ahora lo
libera lo devolvió a la cárcel en 2018 a
principios de marzo fue trasladado a una
clínica por problemas cardíacos para las
víctimas de otro caso en su contra el de
las esterilizaciones forzadas la
decisión de la corte desvanece la
justicia veamos más en el informe que
preparamos para ustedes desde la
redacción de aquí américa el 18 de
septiembre de 1996 nació el cuarto hijo
de maría lina carvajal tras la cesárea
los médicos me llegaron las trompas en
contra de su voluntad
a mí me condicionaron escondieron
y después de muchas horas tuvieron que
exigirme y familiares para que me den
como triste doloroso y no es solamente
se me ha sido a los 25 años que hemos
pasado con nuestra familia nuestra salud
física y mental y ahora los gobiernos
que son indigentes y no nos ayuda la
misma suerte corrieron 300.000 mujeres y
22 mil varones provenientes de grupos
indígenas y pobres debido a un plan de
control de natalidad que el entonces
presidente de perú alberto fujimori
promovió entre 1996 y 2000 fujimori ha
pasado menos de 15 años de los 25 a los
que fue condenado por violaciones a los
derechos humanos
indignadas porque no es justo que hayan
pasado diez y cinco años y volvemos a
cero con nuevamente con el indulto de
alberto fujimori
esto pasó 17 y ahora nuevamente en 22 no
sé de justicia ya más de 25 años el
presidente pedro castillo prometió en
campaña que el estado presentaría
disculpas públicas por las
esterilizaciones forzadas pero ocho
meses después de su elección esta
promesa sigue sin cumplirse mientras que
la decisión del máximo tribunal es para
los peruanos un recordatorio de la
influencia de fujimori en la rama
judicial y legislativa del país fujimori
es una figura divisoria algunos lo ven
como un dictador y otros como un líder
que recuperó la economía y terminó con
el grupo terrorista sendero luminoso
y otro exmandatario americano con
problemas con la justicia es juan
orlando hernández un juez autorizó la
extradición del expresidente de honduras
a eeuu cuya justicia lo solicita por
delitos de narcotráfico y corrupción
veamos el informe de melissa chávez
juan orlando hernández está un paso más
cerca de la extradición en eeuu un juez
de tegucigalpa autorizó la extradición
del ex mandatario quien es solicitado
por narcotráfico corrupción y tráfico de
armas de fuego por una corte de nueva
york los abogados apelaron la decisión
está claro de lo que resulta es una
clara violación a la soberanía una clara
violación a los derechos fundamentales
de la persona que se ordena la
extradición y en su momento a partir de
ahora estas decisiones del poder
judicial generan la respuesta
responsabilidad internacional del estado
de honduras en el marco de los derechos
humanos juan orlando hernández está
detenido desde el 15 de febrero y
continuará bajo arresto en una
instalación militar mientras la corte
suprema decide sobre el recurso de
apelación
eeuu alega que hernández formaba parte
de una operación para enviar a la unión
americana toneladas de cocaína
provenientes de colombia y venezuela
además se le acusa de aceptar millones
de dólares en sobornos para impedir que
narcotraficantes fueran investigados y
llevados a juicio en 2021 una corte de
nueva york condenó hermano de hernández
toni a cadena perpetua por narcotráfico
vamos al sur de nuestro continente en
medio de protestas en contra y de
división en el partido de gobierno el
senado argentino aprobó el acuerdo
alcanzado entre el fondo monetario
internacional y el gobierno de alberto
fernández para refinanciar la deuda de
45.000 millones de dólares con el fondo
monetario internacional que adquirió el
ex presidente mauricio macri el pacto ya
había recibido el visto bueno de la
cámara de diputados la aprobación que
ahora debe recibir una última revisión
del fm y evita que argentina caiga en
cesación de pagos de las obligaciones
previstas para este año con el organismo
y me despido con la imagen de la semana
la primera foto de una estrella lejana
enviada por el telescopio james webb el
potente telescopio de la nasa nos
muestra una estrella bautizada dos más
tras haber despegado de la tierra el
pasado 25 de diciembre y un mes después
de haber llegado a su posición
definitiva el telescopio más caro jamás
puesto en el espacio busca mirar años
luz atrás y descubrir si estamos solos
en el universo
gracias por acompañarnos en esta emisión
de aquí américa en la producción estuvo
a giovanni agudelo envíenme sus
comentarios al en redes sociales en la
dirección que ven en sus pantallas y
para más información de nuestro
continente sigan viendo france24
[Música]